as a man now your the game has changed  in the game of chess sometimes it's not  about winning it's about making sure you  don't lose if you cannot lose if you  could not blunder any pieces and protect  your king long enough you'll win the  game and there's a lot of men who are  now like okay how do I not lose well you  know what I become [ __ ] ruthless  that's how I don't lose I get I get all  my sex because the women are promiscuous  I get laid as much as I want I don't let  anyone [ __ ] tie me into anything dumb  any [ __ ] wants to get fresh to me or  [ __ ] talk to another dude I cut her  off financially but man you just forget  ruthless so you don't lose the game but  that's because the game's been rigged  against men so the harder you rig the  game against us the more ruthless we're  gonna have to be to compete and that's  it's unfortunate I'm not saying I have  the answers I'm just saying why men do  what they do